bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 seul l'actus 7,8 la q2 ce
lundi 16 septembre voici les titres que
nous allons développer ce soir arnaud
montebourg fleur pellerin et et benoît
hamon trois ministres sur le site de
adsl en cours ce matin pour ce premier
déplacement autour de la nouvelle france
industrielle 34 priorité pour la france
de demain est exposée la semaine de la
mobilité et vient de débuter opération
européen afin de promouvoir les modes de
déplacement alternatifs focus dans ce
journal sur vos habitudes en la matière
et sur les infrastructures de saint
quentin en yvelines à 12 millions de
visiteurs pour la cuvée 2013 est des
journées du patrimoine c'est aussi bien
que l'an dernier
la 17e' 1000 sites étaient ouverts au
public et dans les yvelines nous
reviendrons sur les visites proposées en
préfecture de versailles mais aussi dans
une mosquée a plaisir à l'image du jour
c'est le nouveau permis de conduire
disponible depuis aujourd'hui mais
uniquement pour les nouveaux lauréats
l'examen au format carte de crédit les
permis délivrés entre le 19 janvier le
15 septembre 2013 seront échangées
progressivement jusqu'en 2014
pour tous les autres soit près de 38
millions de titres à l'ancien format il
faudra attendre au plus tard 2033
inutile donc de se rendre en préfecture
les modalités des champs où seront
dévoilés plus tard
dans le détail ce nouveau permis se veut
plus solide bien sûr que l'ancien papier
rose plus petits aussi de la taille je
vous le disais d'une carte de crédit il
est surtout plus difficile à falsifier
grâce à sa carte à puce
ce permis new look aussi en vigueur dans
l'union européenne l'a 34 plan de gros
cons qui est industrielle celle annonces
du gouvernement et de son ministre du
redressement productif énergies
renouvelables tgv du futur industries du
bois font partie des priorités des
objectifs fixés pour rivaliser avec les
autres pays pour lancer ce plan baptisé
la nouvelle france industrielle arnaud
montebourg fleur pellerin benoît hamon
trois ministres étaient à l encours au
siège de cassidian filiale d' eads est
de marché ont plus particulièrement été
évoqué la cybersécurité est mais aussi
le début
de la 4g clair combien et jonathan vilma
le ministre du redressement productif
annoncé la semaine dernière le lancement
de 34 plan de reconquête industrielle
le but rendre nos secteurs innovants
plus concurrentiel sur le marché mondial
ce lundi arnaud montebourg a voulu
prouver que ces plans d'actions sont
déjà en marche
au programme une visite avec d'autres
membres du gouvernement où siègent de
cassidian à elancourt filiale d' eads
vous défendez bien la prendre les
sauveurs des ingénieurs spécialisés dans
deux secteurs clés le développement des
réseaux 4g en tête et la cyber sécurité
nous investissons là où nous pouvons
obtenir les créations d'emplois l'art de
la guerre
comme disait tous les stratèges
militaires c'est de concentrer nos
forces sur les points forts et non pas
les disperser sur nos points faibles des
partenariats public privé sont donc
mises en place investissements notamment
en recherche et développement et
évolution de la législation dans le
numérique on évoque le nombre de 150
mille emplois créés ou sauvés et plus de
15 milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée
générée pour nous c'est une formidable
boostant le développement de nos
affaires en particulier les
investissements r&d qui sont liées à ça
en étant beaucoup on attend beaucoup
d'investissements des temps ce domaine
là un état régalien doit investir
massivement ces technologies
c'est l'idée de ce plan et donc on nous
pour nous on se souvient très positive
les plans d'actions dans le secteur
numérique prévoit également de plancher
sur lies éducation l'hôpital numériques
ou encore les objets connectés une
semaine européenne dédiée à la mobilité
elle débute aujourd'hui avec pour
objectif de sensibiliser à l'utilisation
des transports publics du vélo également
et puis elle doit également servir à
encourager
elle est commune à investir dans les
infrastructures à nécessaire invités de
cette édition humaines les gars bonsoir
vous est ce le directeur des transports
et déplacements pour la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on va débuter par ce dernier point la
question des infrastructures aujourd'hui
globalement l'agglomération est elle
bien équipé pour justement utiliser le
bus le vélo pour se déplacer pour aller
travailler
l'agglomération à mon sens c est bien
équipé puisque
nous avons un réseau structurant
actuellement existants sur les
principales lignes ferroviaires donc les
lignes qui vont à montparnasse qui vont
à la défense et puis le verre versez qui
va sur le centre de l'agglomération
parisienne
parallèlement nous avons tout un réseau
de bus qui est très structuré donc plus
de 32 lignes
un réseau qui est peut-être le deuxième
plus important réseau de grande couronne
de la région parisienne donc un réseau
très important que nous continuons à
renforcer de manière régulière
vous irez veiller régulièrement les
évolutions des différentes lignes on
surveille dont les demandes tout à fait
on surveille d'une manière très
régulière et d'une manière permanente
effectivement la fréquentation des
ajustements sont opérés quasiment
annuellement actuellement pour
effectivement s'adapter au mieux à
l'offre notamment sur le transport
scolaire on a fait de très gros efforts
depuis deux ans sur transport scolaire
de manière à améliorer la desserte pour
les lycéens et les collégiens et puis
parallèlement effectivement les
dessertes vers les entreprises et les
pôles d'emploi sont également très
fortement regarder parce que c'est un
enjeu majeur pour les entreprises c'est
le déplacement des salariés en aient une
accessibilité optimum pour pour les
entreprises c'est important elle
participe à la semaine de la mobilité
sur saint-quentin aussi tout à fait
d'une manière très active
on a une participation importante des
entreprises lui tente reprise cette
semaine participer effectivement à nos
côtés sur la semaine de la mobilité
ce sont des animations qui sont faites
en entreprise organisé par les
entreprises sur des thématiques bien
spécifique pour donner un exemple par
exemple snecma fait une thématique
spécifique sur la sécurité donc il ya
des interventions pour faire des
révisions des véhicules des salariés des
voiture tonneau
orange par exemple fait une thématique
sur tout ce qui concerne la marche à
pied les circulations douces et puis
eads et thales par exemple sur le
secteur de la fesum pierrefonds des
thématiques sur la mobilité électrique a
vu des véhicules électriques est ce
qu'on vient de voir d'ailleurs un
instant avec les déplacements de
ministres ils ne sont pas venus avec
vous reçoit maintenant ils sont bien
venus avec un cortège de voitures on les
a forcément bien vu elle régulièrement
vous également révisé le pld c'est le
plan local de déplacement alors là les
entreprises aussi il participe pour vous
avez reçues sur ce plateau à la fin de
la saison dernière pour faire un petit
point on peut peut-être rappeler
l'importance du pnb en quoi ça consiste
et puis où vous en êtes actuellement
puisqu'il est en train d'être révisée
alors le pld est la déclinaison locale
du plan de déplacements urbains d'île de
france qui est un schéma qui donne les
grandes orientations en vue de favoriser
les modes actifs et
les transports en commun les objectifs
pour duper des us et d'obtenir dans les
dix ans à venir
un report modal avec un développement
des transports en commun de plus de 20%
sur les modes actifs + 10 % et de
limiter la croissance de l'automobile
voir de la réduire à 2 %
la déclinaison que nous avons fait sur
saint quentin qui a été effectivement
arrêté par le conseil communautaire le
27 juin
cette année 2013 effectivement s'inscrit
dans cette dynamique avec tout un
ensemble d'orientations et une ambition
très importante de manière à
effectivement rendre encore plus
attractif tous les modes alternatifs ou
mais c'est possible ça veut dire réduire
l'utilisation de la voiture c'est les
autres jacques gillot pic non je ne
pense pas que ce soit utopique puisque
ce que l'on constate notamment par
l'évolution des pôles d'emploi comme le
secteur de l'axé saint pierre on a eu
des renforcements par exemple très
significatif qui est significatif
excusez-moi de la ligne 15 et sur cette
ligne 15 ce qu'on constate c'est lé
renforcement permanent de cette ligne
amène une fréquentation toujours
croissante et on a effectivement un
certain nombre de salariés qui se
rabattent sur les transports en commun
et pas plus tard que ce matin on a eu
aussi une activité une animation dans le
cadre de la semaine de la mobilité sur
le technocentre et la plupart des 400
personnes qu'on a vu ce matin au
technocentre poser des questions pour
savoir comment effectivement utiliser
des modes alternatifs au véhicule
sachant que la voiture restera quand
même un mode incontournable et puis on
aura peut-être aussi des améliorations
significatives et que le covoiturage
dynamique qui permettront au fil
effectivement d'améliorer une chose pour
le technocentre du côté de guyancourt
puisqu'on parlait auparavant de la clé
saint-pierre à elancourt de l'autre côté
de l'agglomération semaine européenne de
la mobilité qui débute donc aujourd'hui
l'agglomération de saint quentin il
participe vous l'avez entendu on va
évoquer un peu plus en détail le
programme de cette semaine qui concerne
le grand public ce sera juste après ce
micro trottoir c'est notre question du
jour
prenez vous les transports en commun et
pourquoi non j'habite à 53 kilomètres de
mon travail donc pas possible de prendre
le train il n'y a pas assez de trains il
n'y a pas ces bus de la gare de
saint-quentin pour venir ici
j'habite à 15 kilomètres donc je trouve
ça plus pratique de prendre ma voiture
il n'y a pas de transport de ligne
directe entre plaisir et 50 ans alors je
prends les transports en commun de temps
en temps entre sancerre et saint quentin
et
comme il ya une piste cyclable je vous
avoue que quand je peux rentrer à pied
ou venir à pied j'ai un pied
non parce que j'habite vers dreux et que
les transports en commun ne sont pas il
n'a pas assez je prends le bus parce que
c'est plus rapide pour venir
non parce qu'il ya une correspondance et
en fin de compte uc en plus de temps de
trajet que si j'ai en voiture on
j'habite à côté de mantes-la-jolie donc
du coup c'est pas simple pour venir
jusqu'ici et que le trafic
donc voilà je prends les transports en
commun et les gens qui habitent très
loin en général des difficultés pour
venir en transports en commun vous
regardez ce qui se passe au delà de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines vous vous échanger avec les
autres communes les autres
agglomérations
oui pour deux mois j'ai analysé un peu
oui on fait on a fait un très gros
effort là depuis une année notamment et
en lien avec le syndicat des transports
d'île de france pour renforcer nos
lignes interurbaines d'intervalle se
dire de nos lignes qui vont au delà
effectivement du pôle de saint quentin
et on a eut obtenu des renforcements sur
5 lignes importantes notamment la
liaison vers massy orly la liaison vers
cergy et poissy la liaison vers saint
cloud et puis également des liaisons
entre saint rémy et puis
et puis
dans l'actualité il est aussi question
en ce moment de cette hausse de la tva
qui s'appliquera à l'année prochaine sur
les transports de 5 5% à 10% pour un
pass navigo pour les parisiens par
exemple à l'abonnement mensuel passerait
de 62 90 à 64 66 est ce que ça peut
freiner le développement des transports
en commun cette hausse de la tva sur les
transports c'est ce que disent les verts
et il demande au gouvernement de revoir
un petit peu la copie là dessus je pense
pouvoir d'aller vers la gratuité global
là il faudrait effectivement peut-être
me des noms qui a été voir a posteriori
quels sont les impacts
je pense que les freins principaux à
l'usagé des transports en commun sont
plutôt liés à la qualité de l'offre de
service qui est offert c'est à dire la
fréquence une amplitude et la régularité
est ce que l'on constate notamment sur
51 quand on met en place d'une offre
très fortement structuré très cadencée
avec une amplitude on obtient des
résultats très significatifs avec des
fréquentations élevé bien évidemment
dans le contexte actuellement de crise
des augmentations tarifaires sont
peut-être forcément maintenant elles
restent quand même modérée et
effectivement il faut qu'on obtienne en
vis-à-vis de ces augmentations de tarifs
un renforcement très importante des
offres ce qu'on a obtenu notamment ceux
basés sur la qualité véritablement pour
répondre aux attentes des usagers
en attendant cette hausse de la tva et
2014 on peut s'attarder à l'inauguration
de la gare de saint-quentin à montigny
le bretonneux
plus précisément ce sera le 18 septembre
c'est une rénovation d'envergure c'est
une gare flambant neuf quels sont les
changements qui ont été apportés
donc cette dynamique s'est inscrit dans
le cadre d'un contrat de paul très
important puisque c'est une enveloppe de
24 millions qui a été allouée dans le
cadre d'un partenariat avec la région on
éteint le conseil général les communes
et puis effectivement la côte et
acclamations donc on a une
restructuration très importante
l'ensemble des personnes de 50 ans ont
pu se rendre compte des événements de la
rénovation de la
la salle des pas perdus les travaux qui
sont légalement sur le secteur du
tilleul la rénovation au nord de la gare
avec la création d'une nouvelle gare
routière sur la rd 10 et l'ouverture
nous tendons vers le quartier du pas du
lac
et puis il ya également cette nouvelle
ligne puisqu'on parle de l'inauguration
de la guerre vous avez mentionné à la
gare routière s'était déjà vendredi
dernier le lancement officiel de ces
nouvelles lignes de bus 50 ans massy 50
à orly
un bus toutes les 15 minutes aux heures
de pointe au départ de la gare de
montigny donc des lignes
ouvert toute la semaine à noter
également que l'ensemble des courses
desservent le technocentre renault à
guyancourt on va écouter le directeur de
la société en charge de l'exploitation
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est une ligne qui existe depuis 1996
et qui a connu des développements
successifs et là on est heureux de
mettre en place aux derniers
développements qui permet aujourd'hui de
relier
saint quentin en yvelines à massy et
orly
tous les jours de l'année du lundi au
vendredi puis le samedi le dimanche et
les jours fériés et les onze jours de
semaine aux heures de pointe on propose
une cadence mans de 15 minutes en heures
de pointe soit vers ma cisma vers orly
j'étais une demande des usagers de la
collectivité du stif et on a travaillé
en partenariat tous ensemble pour offrir
cette belle offre de transport
aujourd'hui voilà pour ces nouvelles
lignes saint-quentin vinci saint quentin
orly tous ses lancements qui se font
dans le cadre de la semaine de la
mobilité qui se poursuit jusqu'au 22
septembre de cette année ça a commencé
aujourd'hui on évoquer les différents
rendez vous on a parlé de l'inauguration
de la gare il y aura des points
d'information aussi qui seront organisés
et plus la possibilité de participer à
ce sera le 18 septembre à ce jeu
concours avec un petit questionnaire un
petit quizz voilà à quoi va servir ce
surprise on peut gagner quoi ce quiz de
la mobilité des nombreux lots dont un
vélo donc été nombreux lots qui sont
effectivement les jacuzzi ou non
campagne twizy mais chacun peut aller
sur le site internet de l'agglomération
pour voir les lots mais des lots liés
mais évidemment la mobilité avec des
séries de questions jusqu'à quel âge est
on autorisé à circuler en vélo sur les
trottoirs 5 8 ou 15 ans je sais que vous
avez révisé juste avant tout à fait
alors là les réponses mais je ne la
donne pas puisque l'on doive répondre
c'est trop facile mais je vous assure
que vous connaissez la réponse je vous
ai entendu tout à l'heure un indice
c'est pas cinq essais pas 15 voilà je
voulais choisir trois possibilités
j'évoquais la twizy
c'est un important aussi à 50 est ennuyé
est-ce que ça a bien marché la
possibilité d'utiliser cette twizy en
partenariat avec renault avec le
technocentre la possibilité de la loue
et de la laisser à peu près où on veut
dans saint quentin en yvelines
les résultats qu'on a de l'enquète mon
truc 92% des personnes qui utilisent le
service twizy en sont très satisfaits
donc il ya un vrai engouement pour ceux
qui l'utilisent avec une vraie adhésion
au service
actuellement on a plus de 1000 personnes
qui sont effectivement inscrits sur ce
service un nouvel opérateur vient de
reprendre le service à la suite de
renault qui est une société une pme qui
surmonte inique s'appelle lucky move
donc c'est un service qui je suis
convaincu répondent à des besoins et à
des besoins qui se renforcent cette
petite voiture électrique pour son
savoir sur les déplacements
saint-quentin-en-yvelines guide de la
mobilité il a été mise à jour pouvez
vous le procurer sur le site de
l'agglomération de saint quentin ou
directement dans vos locaux également
emmanuelle weill a été l'invité de cette
édition en charge des transports et
déplacements sur l'agglomération
j'avais quand même une dernière question
le transport de demain vous l'imaginez
comment où là c'est une question
difficile
les avait trente secondes en termes de
mobilité individuelle on pense que on
aura certainement des choses
relativement automatisé qui permettront
certainement de limiter toutes les dix
ont les problèmes de fluidité
les problèmes de d'accidentologie donc
il ya des choses notamment qui commence
à se mettre en place avec des véhicules
qui se garent automatiquement tout seuls
des véhicules qui peuvent se déplacer
plus ou moins tout seul donc on a un
pôle de compétitivité qu'elle paul movéo
qui est basé à satory qui réfléchit à
ces mobilités un petit peu automatisées
qui peuvent être intéressantes dans les
baies dans l'e mobilité entre guillemets
plus ou moins individuelle et je sais
que vous voulez ajouter quelque chose
oui je voulais dire juste un petit mot
concernant la semaine de la mobilité
pour le grand public mercredi
il ya tout un ensemble d'animations
hangar qui sont je pense intéressante
avec du gravage pour ceux qui ont des
vélos aggravée avec la police depuis en
cours qui sera présente donc on pourra
faire graver son vélo il ya également de
l'office de tourisme et la maison
le excusez moi le musée de la ville qui
fait des malades ou si on ville et puis
on a un réparateur volo vélo aussi à
partir de 14h ou si le mercredi 18 qui
réparera les vélos de ceux qui
souhaitent effectivement se remettre à
faire du vélo
programme complet de cette semaine de la
mobilité sur le site internet de
l'agglomération et puis aussi une
promenade à vélo le 21 septembre à 14
heures départ devant la gare merci à
vous toutes autres sujets à présent
l'agencé du crédit agricole a été
victime d'un braquage les faits se sont
déroulés vendredi en fin de semaine
dernière début d'après midi près du
distributeur de billets un homme cagoulé
a surgi du plafond il a demandé à
l'employé qui rechargeait la machine de
lui ouvrir le sas sécurisés le braqueur
a tout simplement découper le plafond à
la scie sauteuse
cet audacieux un peu plus tôt dans la
journée et en toute tranquillité
la somme volée n'a pas été dévoilée l'an
4 revient à la brigade de répression du
banditisme de la police judiciaire de
versailles
à magny les hameaux le centre commercial
du quartier du buisson entame une
rénovation de trois mois la ville et le
bailleur social opievoy finance les
travaux d'un montant de 223 euros
l accès au magasin sera maintenue mais
des places de stationnement seront
supprimées il faudra s'adapter à terme
l'auvent sera détruit les menuiseries
remplacés et les façades repeintes
les journées du patrimoine se sont
déroulés ce week end et le bilan est bon
malgré la pluie plusieurs sites vont
attirer les visiteurs a commencé dans
les yvelines par le bâtiment qui abrite
à versailles la préfecture et le conseil
général un bâtiment construit pendant le
second empire qui accueillit notamment
est des personnages célèbres comme
adolphe thiers ou encore deux présidents
de la république mcmahon et jules grévy
le reportage de catherine plateau et de
jonathan willeman mais regardez quand
même la beauté
du décor et surtout cette quantité d'or
d'alexis napoléon iii il avait une
initiative un peu intimidé les visiteurs
en entrant dans la salle du conseil
général ce dimanche forcément les lieux
qui abrite à la fois la préfecture et
les bureaux du département ont de quoi
faire briller les yeux d'autant plus
quand on sait que ces bâtiments
construits sous le second empire ont
accueilli d'illustrés personnages
adolphe thiers ou encore deux présidents
de la république et mac mahon et jules
grévy à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine toutes les salles étaient
accessibles et dans le parc on pouvait
croiser le préfet et le président du
conseil général le département c'est
plus modeste que vous avez gardé le
balcon oui j'ai même pas monté
des visiteurs conquis à la fois par les
lieux et par ces journées ça donne accès
à tout un tas de deux monuments de
bâtiments que nous ne pourrions pas
visité pendant le reste de l'année et
en même temps ceux des bâtiments qui
appartiennent à tout le monde
j'ai trouvé que c'était un très joli
bâtiment splendide avec qui
une histoire
c'est unique puisque 7 et en même temps
au 19e le siège du gouvernement
le jardin est très beau très agréable
voilà enfin jeu ça ressemble un peu au
château ces visites ont attiré quelques
2500 personnes pendant tout le week end
autres visites proposées durant ces
journées du patrimoine celle de la
mosquée de plaisir l'occasion de
découvrir le lieu mais aussi le culte
musulman et le rôle de l'imam
un reportage de yolaine thorez et de
jonathan vilma c'était une des visites
insolites du week end la mosquée de
plaisir a ouvert ses portes au grand
public pour les journées du patrimoine
l'occasion de faire tomber les préjugés
c'est important aujourd'hui de de donner
une autre image redora un peu l'image de
l'islam et de notre communauté parce qu
on entend énormément de choses dans les
médias et là ça nous permet d'avoir
vraiment une tribune une tribune pour
pouvoir se présenter pas pour en parler
mais pour que les gens viennent vraiment
nous voir c'est une reconnaissance pour
nous pour notre communauté aujourd'hui
de pouvoir être associé au patrimoine
quelques curieux ont fait le déplacement
elle écoute de l'histoire de cette
mosquée qui date de plus de dix ans ce
n'est pas là la seule occasion de
visiter le lieu toute l'année cours de
soutien scolaire est sorti entre adultes
et enfants ils sont organisés avec
l'association on tombe pas dans
l'extrémisme en parlant ce qu'on raconte
dans les médias de vouloir être dans
notre bulle isolée de tout on est en
contact très régulier
avec ce soit à la mairie des
associations reçoit des écoles dire on
passe par un certain nombre de deux
rencontres et des relations extérieures
au quotidien la mosquée de plaisir fait
partie des 68 mosquée du département
demain dans le 7-8 là que tu je recevrai
le responsable de la mission éducative
dead et actions france basée à
coignières il sera question d'un
documentaire que soutient l'association
et qui nous fait découvrir le quotidien
de quatre enfants du kenya de l'atlas
marocain de l'inde et de la patagonie
quatre enfants et qui ne pourront s'en
sortir que par l'éducation sur le chemin
de l'école c'est le nom de ce film
documentaire est signé pascal plisson il
sort en salles le 25 septembre il sera
projeté en avant première demain mardi à
l'ugc de montigny le bretonneux
le montant des recettes sera reversée à
et des actions la réservation est
obligatoire à l'adresse internet qui
s'est affichée et des actions et milite
pour l'accès de tous à l'école depuis
1981 l'an dernier à la soutenu 119
projets dans 25 pays
un mot de ce sport à présent en baseball
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux ne
disputeront pas la finale de 2e division
battus ce week-end à domicile pourtant
par pessac
une rencontre est très incertaine mais
qui a échappé aux locaux comme nous
l'expliquent anthony rech
après le froid de cet hiver et la longue
interruption de l'été avant les playoffs
les organismes mini montain semble usée
mais à quelques jours d'une demi finale
retour décisive
arnaud faux l'entraîneur des couguars
préfère oublier la déception du match
aller et va tout faire pour remobiliser
ses joueurs
toulouse est peut-être un petit peu
fatigué oui mais bien une finale ça ça
vaut le coup ok les re motiver
on veut pas motiver quelqu'un qui ne
l'est pas mais sûr qu'ils sont tous un
petit peu motivé ce qu'on souhaite c'est
de faire c'est de les allumer la petite
flamme qu'ils ont au match aller cette
petite flamme avait quitté lésigny
montant manquant d'agressivité de
précision ils se sont inclinés par deux
fois pessac les demi finales de division
2 se joue au meilleur des cinq matches
les cougars ne doivent plus perdre pour
espérer voir la finale
complètement dos au mur à il faut gagner
trois matches tant que c'est pas fini on
est encore là on a joué chez eux on va
jouer chez nous on a quand même quelques
jalili retour maintenant on a quelques
points de notre côté quand même la
survie des cougars passe d'abord par un
premier match couperet ce samedi après
midi pour ne pas vivre une fin de saison
cauchemardesque
dès les premiers lancés le sort
s'acharne sur les cougars en plus du
handicap de deux matchs à remonter des
trombes d'eau s'abattent sur jean
maréchal
la rencontre doit être interrompu les
cougars vont devoir jouer trois manches
sur une journée quasiment du jamais vu
le lendemain gonflées comme des cocottes
minutes lésigny montain s'impose
finalement dans ce premier match 12
points 2 bis repetita dans la seconde
rencontre 13,2 en faveur des joueurs
d'arnaud faut les home run s'enchaînent
et tout le peuple saint quentinois croit
alors à l'exploit mais les plus garante
à mal ce match décisif et dans la
huitième manche
un défenseur de pessac réalise un catch
magnifique qui donne la victoire aux
panthères 6,5
la marche de la finale aura été trop
haute pour les animaux teint qui
pourront regretter longtemps leurs ratés
du match aller
la date d'inauguration du vélodrome
dévoilé il s'agira du 30 janvier 2014
rappelons que ce site à montigny le
bretonneux entend devenir le nouveau
clairefontaine du cyclisme nous vous
montrions il y a quelques semaines les
premières images de la pose de la piste
une structure qui sera unique en europe
longue de 250 mètres inclinaison plus
importante qu'ailleurs également 44
degrés l'anneau du vélodrome est déjà
surnommée la piste record la fédération
et l'équipe de france vont aussi
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
et puis derrière le vélodrome une arène
de bmx est couverte est en train de voir
le jour un projet dont le budget s'élève
à 70 millions d'euros inauguration donc
le 30 janvier 2014
une toute dernière information un clin
d'oeil plutôt à l'heure d'internet les
annuaires papier des pages jaunes
restent très prisées 72 % souhaitent
toujours le recevoir c'est le résultat
d'une enquête qui a été menée par la
société éditrice 52 5% des français
consulterait l'annuaire au moins une
fois par an dans sa version papier
et puis si vous faites partie de cette
majorité sachez que l'édition yvelines
2013 est en cours de distribution en ce
moment
7256 c'est très précis annuaires papier
vont être acheminées rien que pour le
département
c'est la fin de cette édition du journal
du 16 septembre je vous retrouve demain
en direct à 18h pour un nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité locale
excellente soirée sur tv fils